ted freestyle ou band ceux des termes
qui vous sont peut être inconnu si vous
ignorez tout de l'univers du hip hop
avec ce parcours immersif et
participatif le prisme et la compagnie
par terre propose une découverte en
images les visiteurs entre 10 mai vont
danser et rendre vivante
l'exposition donc voilà c'est des
petites installations et à chaque
installation il ya un jeu à faire une
consigne un déguisement un pas et voilà
même si on sait pas danser finalement on
arrive à expérimenter la dans ce cas
c'est hyper encadrés et accompagnés
et avec les nouvelles technologies parmi
les outils présentés une machette et bol
pour devenir le chorégraphe d'une battle
conçu par la braqueuse nguyen danse des
guerriers de la ville c'est aussi un
tour des différents styles et mouvements
de hip hop dans les années soixante dix
il ya eu les danses dites old school de
l'ancienne école donc qui ont émergé sur
les courants funk pour les danses dites
debout donc il ya le pop
donc tout ce qui est contractions
musculaires et le lock qui est plus
issus de tous les fonds qui step de
l'époque et le break le break c'est la
danse au sol et donc les musiques ont
traversé le temps ont changé et ça à
chaque musique finalement le les mêmes
bases sont là mais interprétés
différemment
en parallèle du parcours des ateliers
sont proposés aux visiteurs pour une
initiation avec l'un des guerriers de la
ville la breakdance et le locking
n'auront plus de secrets